porque la semilla de un árbol frutal es una variante genética del padre.
Así que cuando encontramos una variedad que nos gusta mucho,
la forma en que la propagamos es tomando un esqueje de un árbol
e insertándolo en otro,
algo extraño, si se piensa en ello:
cada manzana "Macintosh" procede de un solo árbol
que ha sido injertado una y otra vez de generación en generación.
Pero también significa que los frutales no pueden preservarse por semillas.
He sabido de los injertos desde que tengo memoria.
Mi bisabuelo se dedicaba a injertar huertos de duraznos
en el sudeste de Pensilvania.
Y aunque nunca lo conocí, cuando alguien decía su nombre,
se apresuraban a decir
que sabía injertar como si tuviera una capacidad mágica o mística.
Elegí el número 40 para el Árbol de 40 frutas
porque está presente en la religión occidental,
no como la docena cuantificable ni como el infinito,
sino como un número más allá del cálculo.
Es la abundancia o multiplicidad.
Pero el problema fue que cuando empecé,
no encontraba 40 variedades diferentes de estas frutas,
a pesar de que vivo en el estado de Nueva York
que, hace un siglo,
era uno de los principales productores de estas frutas.
Mientras destruían los huertos de investigación
y los antiguos huertos,
recolectaba sus ramas y las injertaba en los árboles de mi vivero.
Así se veía el Árbol de 40 Frutas cuando fue plantado,
y así luce seis años después.
Sin duda, no es un ejercicio de gratificación inmediata.
(Risas)
Se necesita un año para saber si un injerto ha tenido éxito,
de dos a tres años para saber si produce fruta,
y ocho años para obtener un solo árbol.
Cada variedad injertada en el Árbol de 40 frutas
tiene una forma y un color ligeramente distintos.
Y me di cuenta de que al elaborar un calendario
con las fechas en que floreció cada uno en relación con los otros,
puedo moldear o diseñar el aspecto que tendrán los árboles en primavera.
Así se ven en verano.
Producen fruta de junio a septiembre.
Primero cerezas, luego albaricoques,
ciruelas asiáticas, nectarinas y duraznos,
y creo que olvidé uno por ahí, en algún lugar...
(Risas)
Aunque es una obra de arte fuera de la galería,
mientras el proyecto sigue su curso
es una forma de preservación por medio del arte.
Me han pedido crearlos en distintos lugares,
y para ello investigo las variedades autóctonas
o tradicionalmente cultivadas en la zona en cuestión,
las adquiero localmente y las injerto en el árbol,
así se convierten en historia agrícola del área donde están ubicadas.
Luego el proyecto apareció en Internet,
una experiencia horrorosa y conmovedora.
La parte horrorosa fueron todos los tatuajes que vi
con imágenes del Árbol de 40 frutas.
(Risas)
Pensaba: "¿Por qué le harías eso a tu cuerpo?"
Y la parte conmovedora fueron todos los pedidos que recibí
de párrocos, rabinos y sacerdotes
que me pidieron usar el árbol como parte central de su servicio.
Y entonces se convirtió en un meme
y la respuesta a esa pregunta es: "Espero que no".
[¿Es su matrimonio como el Árbol de 40 frutas?]
(Risas)
Como todo buen meme,
esto llevó a una entrevista en la edición de fin de semana de la emisora NPR,
y como profesor universitario, pensé que había llegado a la cima,
que era el momento cumbre de mi carrera,
pero uno nunca sabe quién escucha la NPR.
Varias semanas después de la entrevista en la radio,
recibí un correo electrónico del Departamento de Defensa.
La Agencia de Proyectos de Investigación Avanzada de la Defensa
me invitó a dar una charla sobre innovación y creatividad,
y la conversación pronto cambió a una discusión sobre seguridad alimentaria.
Verán, nuestra seguridad nacional depende de la seguridad alimentaria.
Ahora que hemos creado monocultivos
que solo producen unas pocas variedades por cosecha,
si algo le pasa a alguna de esas variedades,
puede tener un gran impacto en el suministro alimentario.
Y la clave para mantener nuestra seguridad alimentaria
es preservar la biodiversidad.
Hace 100 años, esto lo hacía cualquiera que tuviera un huerto
o algunos árboles en su jardín
y cultivaba variedades que se pasaban de generación en generación.
Estas son las ciruelas de un solo Árbol de 40 frutas en una semana en agosto.
Tras varios años en el proyecto,
me dijeron que tengo una de las mayores cosechas de estas frutas
en el este de Estados Unidos,
lo que, como artista, es aterrador.
Pero, en gran medida, no sabía lo que tenía.
Descubrí que la mayoría de las variedades que poseía
eran reliquias de aquellas cultivadas antes de 1945,
que se considera el comienzo de la industrialización de la agricultura.
Muchas de las variedades se remontan a miles y miles de años.
Y al descubrir lo poco comunes que eran,
me obsesioné con tratar de preservarlas,
y el medio para hacerlo fue el arte.
Iba a huertos antiguos antes de que los destruyeran
y rescataba la sección del tronco que contenía el injerto original.
Empecé a hacer prensados de flores y hojas para crear especímenes de herbarios.
Comencé a secuenciar el ADN.
Pero al final, decidí preservar la historia
a través de estos grabados y descripciones en tipografía
para contar la historia del durazno "George IV",
que echó raíces entre dos edificios de Nueva York:
alguien que pasaba lo probó
y se convirtió en una variedad comercial muy importante en el siglo XIX,
por lo bueno que estaba.
Pero luego todo se desvaneció,
porque no tenía fácil distribución y no se ajustaba al cultivo moderno.
Pienso que es una historia que debe ser contada.
Y el relato de esa historia
debe incluir la experiencia de poder tocar,
oler y saborear esas variedades.
Así que decidí crear un huerto
para que la fruta estuviera disponible para el público,
con la idea de ubicarlo
donde hubiera la mayor densidad de gente que pudiera encontrar.
Naturalmente, empecé buscando un acre de tierra en Nueva York,
(Risas)
lo que, en retrospectiva, parecía bastante ambicioso
y probablemente la razón por la que nadie respondía a mis llamadas o cartas.
(Risas)
Hasta que, cuatro años después, me contestaron desde Governors Island.
Governors Island es una antigua base naval
donada a la ciudad de Nueva York en el año 2000.
Y ofrecía todo ese terreno
a cinco minutos de transbordo desde Nueva York.
Me invitaron a crear un proyecto al que llamamos "el Huerto Público",
que recuperará variedades frutales
que no se han cultivado en Nueva York por más de un siglo.
Actualmente en marcha,
el Huerto Público tendrá 50 árboles de injertos múltiples
con 200 variedades frutales antiguas.
Son variedades autóctonas o cultivadas de forma tradicional en la región.
Variedades como la manzana "Early Strawberry",
que se originó en la calle 13 y la Tercera Avenida.
Dado que un árbol frutal no se puede preservar por semillas,
el Huerto Público funcionará como un banco genético vivo
o un archivo de estas frutas.
Como el Árbol de 40 frutas, será experimental,
y también será simbólico.
Lo más importante es que invitará a la gente a participar en la conservación
y a aprender más sobre los alimentos.
Por el Árbol de 40 frutas,
he recibido miles y miles de correos electrónicos
que preguntaban cosas básicas sobre cómo se planta un árbol.
Ya que menos del 3 % de la población
tiene un vínculo directo con la agricultura,
el Huerto Público invitará a la gente
a participar en programas públicos y talleres,
a aprender cómo injertar, cultivar, podar y cosechar un árbol;
a hacer recorridos para ver la floración y probar las frutas;
a trabajar con chefs locales para aprender a usar la fruta
y recrear platos con siglos de antigüedad
para los que se cultivaron específicamente muchas de estas variedades.
Más allá del aspecto físico del huerto,
habrá un libro de cocina que recopile todas estas recetas.
Será una guía práctica
sobre las características y los cuidados de esas frutas,
su origen y su historia.
Al crecer en una granja, creí que sabía de agricultura,
y no quise tener nada que ver con ello.
(Risas)
Así que me convertí en artista.
Pero tengo que admitir que es algo que llevo en mi ADN.
Y no creo que sea el único.
Hace 100 años, estábamos mucho más ligados a la cultura,
el cultivo y la historia de nuestra comida,
y nos hemos alejado de ello.
El Huerto Público brinda la oportunidad
de no solo reconectarnos con este pasado desconocido,
sino de considerar cuál podría ser el futuro de nuestra alimentación.
Gracias
(Aplausos)